so step out of line ladies from
empowering speeches to Kim Kardashian
and Kendall Jenner seemingly getting
laughed at onstage telling their stories
unfiltered and unscripted et is taking a
look at the most memorable moments from
the 2019 Emmy Awards the night was a
game of hosts as there was no designated
entertainer to kick off the show
Homer Simpson filled in with this epic
hosting fail which was saved by Anthony
Anderson who then convinced one of the
most celebrated TV actors of all time to
take the stage
Bryan Cranston television has never been
this good Maya Rudolph presented an
award alongside Ike Barinholtz the
comedic duo joke they got LASIK eye
surgery earlier in the day which is why
they couldn't exactly read the
teleprompter here are the Nimrods for
dead ascot in a chocolate circuit Bart
had mouth Barry Dan chowder Black Monday
Abraham aluminium blackish and the
Grammy for leif Garrett in a cowboy suit
goes to it was a big night for fleabag
star Phoebe Waller bridge for
nominations yeah I'm saying
not only did fleabag win Phoebe herself
won twice the Emmy goes to
Phoebe Waller breathe and the Emmy goes
to
Phoebe Waller bridge it was a powerful
evening of speeches Alex Borstein shared
this touching story about her
grandmother a Holocaust survivor
my grandmother turned to a guard she was
in line to be shot into a pit and she
said what happens if I step out of line
and he said I don't have the heart to
shoot you but somebody will and she
stepped out of line and for that I am
here and for that my children are here
so step out of line ladies
Michelle Williams used her speech to
spread an empowering message about equal
pay the next time a woman tells you what
she needs in order to do her job listen
because one day she might stand in front
of you and say thank you for allowing
her to succeed because of her workplace
environment and not in spite of it and
Billy Porter made history as the first
openly gay black man to win in the Lead
Actor category we are the people we as
artists are the people that get to
change the molecular structure of the
hearts and minds of the people who live
on this planet please don't ever stop
doing that but it wouldn't be a true
award show without a few moments that
left us scratching our heads like this
musical number that happened while
presenting the award for best variety
show in Kardashian and Kendall Jenner
presented the award for best competition
series midway through their lines the
audience started laughing our family
knows firsthand how truly compelling
television comes from real people just
being themselves telling their stories
unfiltered and unscripted
[Applause]
you